[Music]
this odd looking machine is called
the tube that is
quite a paper airplane it spins as it
flies it gets its directional stability
from how quickly that it's spinning
but more importantly that's how it
derives its lift
from how fast it's spinning special
boundary layer effect
little gobs of air get stuck on all the
tiny imperfections microscopic
imperfections in the surface of this
plane
and the faster it spins the more it can
interact
with the surrounding air and develop
lift the
upshot is as it's spinning this way it
can shove
enough air off of that side lift it up
like that so
because it's moving forward through the
air like that so very
interesting aircraft round paper
airplane the center of gravity is right
there it's not even
in not even touching the plane it's in
the middle of all that
center of gravity in the middle thin air
and so to fold it we're going to start
with an eight and a half by 11 sheet
and start with the long side up we're
going to fold down one
third and one third means that the
layered part is going to be the same
length as the unlayered part
and it's okay if the layered part is a
little bit bigger
and so to make sure that you're folding
straight get this edge and this edge
lined up and start in the middle and
sweep to the outside
and there's one third fold it over
and you'll notice that's you know
visually you can see that's a little bit
bigger than that which is
that's okay it's actually preferable to
have that a little bit bigger
so don't don't sweat the one-third thing
you don't have to whip out the ruler and
do any of that crazy stuff
just get get about a third over there
now we're going to fold the layer part
in half
bringing the top down to that what used
to be
the top edge of the paper make a nice
sharp crease again
starting in the center and working our
way out
and one more time we're going to fold
the layered part in half right here
just right through there if you started
with anything thicker than 20lb paper
your fingers are going to get a real
workout on this one so
let's roll that over one more time
folding the layered part in half
take your time and line it up try to
control those layers it's a lot of
layers to control
and sweeping to the outside and making a
sharp crease we're going to do something
extraordinary here to sharpen this
crease we're going to pick it up on this
camera over here
and we're going to roll it over the edge
of the table
to sharpen the crease and we're just
going to work it back and forth the
smooth side of the paper is up
uh the layered part is down
nothing against the layer part right
over the corner of the table
makes a great satisfying sound
and now it's going to stand up you can
see it's going to stand up
just like a little tunnel there
you can reach right under it
standing up nicely
now the trick here let's flip it over so
that we have the curved side up
we're going to unfold just the last time
we fold it in half the last time we did
that
and i want you to come down here um to
the right-hand side
of the plane and we're just going to
lift up this corner here
um it's it's layered you can see there's
a loop of paper here
little loop of paper there and i want
you to put a finger inside there
like that
so we're separating the two corners here
the two single layer corners
and there's a double layer corner on top
so you're just going to put a finger
inside there like that
and then grab the other end we're going
to wrap the other end around and put it
right inside there
just like that
and we're going to put it in there about
that much yeah it's a little bit more
than an
inch maybe an inch and a half you know
one thumb width
almost uh one and a half thumb widths
kind of an idea
so again i made that look really easy
and i know it's not
[Laughter]
so i'm gonna lift this top layer here
there's a single layer on either
you get a short single layer and a long
single layer on one side
and i'm going to just put my finger in
there just to hold that open we've got a
double
layer there that's got a corner that's a
crease right there so you have two
layers
and two layers and we're just going to
pick this other end up
roll it around and put it inside there
where our finger is
and slide it in you know inch and a half
or so
and then hang on to it once you get it
together hang on to it because what
we're going to do to lock this plane
together is
follow that crease all the way around
that we unfolded
so what i like to do is start here
hold on to it where the where the layers
overlap
where you put it one inside the other
and push it down right there
i like to reach up inside here with a
finger and just kind of hold that
crimp that down like that that'll help
you as you're remaking the crease and
this is gonna get ugly i'm warning you
now
it's gonna get ugly here we go
it's getting ugly it's getting really
ugly
it's getting very ugly and then suddenly
when you get all the way around there it
starts to get beautiful look at that
it goes from very ugly to very beautiful
in just just a moment like that
and now we're going to push in just so
you can see
i'm rounding it out just by going around
there
smoothing it out and it becomes
really kind of an extraordinary circle
here
okay let's flip it over this is the
heavy side up with all the layers there
you can see all the layering right there
let's turn it over just briefly here
right here is what we're going to fix
next
this is the tail of the plane it's
popping open there a little bit
i don't like that some people leave that
open you can leave that open if you want
it will affect the flight i feel like it
adds a little bit of drag so what i'm
going to do
is just go around that edge about
i don't know two three millimeters you
know something like
a little bit less than a quarter of an
inch i'm just going to go all the way
around the back of the plane
just moving that to the inside
and then just kind of pinching it
to smooth that out and that really looks
a lot better
holds together a lot better it's going
to be smoother through the air there's
your tube
now there's no real adjusting here this
is it
there's no control surfaces you're going
to throw it and it's going to rotate
like that you're going to throw it let
it roll off your fingertips
if you've ever thrown a spiral football
that's kind of what you're going for
so if you've never thrown a spiral
football it's actually
kind of easy to learn how to do it with
this tube start by throwing it like this
and just giving it some backspin and
don't worry about how far it's going
just worry about developing a good
amount of spin
just like that and you know throw it a
few times so that you're kind of getting
the hang of it imparting some good spin
here
and once you got the hang of making it
spin just turn your wrist like this
same kind of motion down like that and
let it go that way
and so that's a good way to learn how to
throw this guy and you can give it a
fairly hard toss it really likes
a really good solid throw give it a lot
of spin really hard throw
and you wrap your finger around it where
the thick part is
don't do it here with us it'll squish on
you but get up here where the thick part
is
wrap your finger around it and then
really give it a good hard spin
and a good hard throw it should zip out
there 60 70 feet no problem
uh it's a great indoor plane it's a
little bit crazy to throw outdoors you
can't really tell what it's doing
sometimes it gets caught in the wind and
does crazy things
really fun plane to learn how to make
extraordinary to learn how to fly it's
the tube
you